dave uh you know we uh we all reminisced
at the top of the show about our new
year's resolutions have you made any
have you
made any promises for the new year yes
and this is a big one a big one for me
i'm uh i'm going to change my style of
comedy i have i have been offensive to
too many people
and them days are over like and please
don't get mad like sometimes you'll hear
my act and i might do a white voice
part of your ass you you're part of your
act you're going to right i'll do a
white character right
it might sound a little like this but
when i do those characters i am not
making fun of the way that white people
talk
i am parodying a simple aspect of the
white speech pattern
that is the absence of rhythm in it
[Laughter]
that's right now
it's the same way you might hear a white
comedian personally black guy now how's
he gonna say him
say my man what's happening
now i do not get mad conan right right i
can see how to a white guy a black guy
might actually sound like that
sing-songy musical show me what you're
working with
[Laughter]
and one is not better than the other as
a matter of fact the white one has a
gift in it because white people have a
gift where you could say terrible things
and it don't sound terrible with that
speech pat really i hear it all the time
job interviews
i'm sorry mr poe we're just not hiring
anyone else
but we'll keep you in mind if something
opens up i'm like yeah
keep me in mind
it sounds kind of pleasant it sounds
i've been kicked out of restaurants by
white dudes now black dudes kicked me
out of places and involves guns and
fists
why do kick you out nice as pie
sir i'm afraid i'm gonna have to ask you
to leave
hey
he said he's afraid to ask me
i believe him uh-huh
now
this is just a
theory but maybe
just maybe that's the reason that most
newscasters are white people
think about it if you think of all the
bad things the newscaster has to say
i would much rather hear that from a
white person than from one of us
you've heard it today in kosovo babies
were kicked like footballs
monsters ate the corn
famine murder
we'll have michael sports right after
this i'm at a crib like hey
sports is coming up
kick like football
interesting that's right having a
brother scare the hell out of you this
just in oh people's dying all over the
street
[Applause]
thank you earl that was earl watkins our
blackfield correspondent in kosovo
with that dramatic retelling of events
oh man we'll have more with earl after
he combs his black ass man
i realized it'd be a bunch
dave i i say it every time you're here
but you are one of my favorite guests
you're always funny and this is my
favorite show man thank you so much for
doing it dave chappelle everybody